sole state of another great power if
you're going to brexit in the way
they're saying okay professor it's great
to talk to you thanks for joining us on
the sky news this afternoon
so you can see the president and
the prime minister heading now towards
the podium so that they will
tell the waiting press awaiting media
about the conversations that they've
been having
so far today it's been a working morning
working breakfast working
lunch as far as melania trump is
concerned she's been in central london
with
philip may and they have been to see
veteran the holding hands again look at
that
uh they've been to see veterans and
school children today chelsea pensioners
um let's see what was achieved with
these two here we go official visit to
the united kingdom
no two countries do more together than
ours to keep their people safe
and prosperous and we want to deepen
that cooperation
even further to meet the shared
challenges we face
now and in the years ahead this morning
president trump and i visited sandhurst
where we saw a demonstration of joint
working between british and american
special forces
just one example of what is today the
broadest
deepest and most advanced security
cooperation of any two countries in the
world
whether it is our pilots deterring the
use of chemical weapons in syria
or defeating daesh our soldiers at the
forefront of nato's presence in eastern
europe
our navies in the pacific enforcing
sanctions on north korea
or our unparalleled intelligence-sharing
partnership
thwarting attacks our security
cooperation is saving lives here
in britain in america and right across
the world
that partnership is set to grow with our
armies integrating to a level
unmatched anywhere and the uk
set to spend 24 billion pounds on u.s
equipment and support over the next
decade
today we've also discussed how we can
deepen our work together to respond to
malign state activity
terrorism and serious crime in
particular on russia
i thanked president trump for his
support in responding to the appalling
use
of a nerve agent in salisbury after
which he expelled
60 russian intelligence officers and i
welcomed his meeting with president
putin in helsinki
on monday we agreed that it is important
to engage russia from a position of
strength and unity
and that we should continue to deter and
counter all efforts to undermine our
democracies
turning to our economic cooperation with
mutual investment between us already
over one trillion dollars
we want to go further we agreed today
that as the uk leaves the european union
we will pursue an ambitious us uk free
trade agreement
the checkers agreement reached last week
provides the platform for donald and me
to agree an ambitious deal that works
for both countries right across our
economies
a deal that builds on the uk's
independent trade policy
reducing tariffs delivering a gold
standard in financial services
cooperation
and as two of the world's most advanced
economies
seizing the opportunity of new
technology
all of this will further enhance our
economic cooperation
creating new jobs and prosperity for our
peoples for generations to come
the uk us relationship is also defined
by the role we play on the world stage
doing this means making tough calls and
sometimes being prepared to say things
that others might rather not hear
from the outset president trump has been
clear about how he sees
the challenges we face and on many we
agree
for example the need to deal with the
long-standing nuclear threat of dprk
where the agreement in singapore has set
in train the prospect of
denuclearization
to which the uk is proud to be
contributing expertise
all the need to address the
destabilizing influence of iran in the
middle east
where today we've discussed what more we
can do to push back on iran
in yemen and reduce humanitarian
suffering
or the need for nato allies to increase
their defence spending and capability
on which we saw significant increases at
yesterday's summit
this includes afghanistan where this
week i announced a further uplift of 440
uk troops
an ongoing commitment to a mission that
began as nato's only use of article 5
acting in support of the us
finally let me say this about the wider
transatlantic relationship
it is all of our responsibility to
ensure that transatlantic unity endures
for it has been fundamental to the
protection and projection
of our interests and values for
generations
u s leadership at its foundation its
beating heart remains our democratic
values and our commitment
to justice those values are something
that we in the uk will always cherish
as i know the us will too it is the
strength of these values
and the common interests they create
that we see across the breadth of our
societies in north america and europe
and that is why i'm confident that this
transatlantic alliance will continue to
be the bedrock of our shared
security and prosperity for years to
come
mr president thank you very much thank
you
prime minister thank you very much and
it is my true honor to
join you at this remarkable setting
truly magnificent
as we celebrate the special relationship
between our two countries
on behalf of the american people i want
to thank you for your
very gracious hospitality thank you very
much teresa
last night melania and i were delighted
to join you and phillip for dinner
at the magnificent blenheim palace it
was a wonderful and memorable
evening that we will not soon forget it
was really something very special
today it's a true privilege to visit
historic checkers that i've heard so
much about and read so much about
growing up in history class and to
continue our
conversation which has really proceeded
along rapidly and well over the last few
days
for generations our predecessors have
gathered at this stunning retreat
to strengthen a bond that is like no
other
the relationship between our two nations
is indispensable to the cause
of liberty justice and peace the united
kingdom and the united states are bound
together by a common historic heritage
language and heroes the traditions of
freedom
sovereignty and the true rule of law
were our shared gift to the world they
are now our
priceless inheritance to a civilization
we must never cease to be
united in their defense and in their
renewal before our dinner last night
melania and i joined
prime minister may mr may and the duke
and duchess of marlborough
for a tour of the winston churchill
exhibit
at blenheim palace it was something
something very
special it was from right here at
checkers that prime minister churchill
phoned president roosevelt
after pearl harbor in that horrific war
american and british service members
bravely shed their blood
alongside one another in defense of home
and in defense of freedom and together
we achieved
a really special
magnificent victory and it was total
victory
prime minister may and i have just come
from a very productive nato summit that
was truly a productive summit
where my top priority was getting other
nato members to pay their
full and fair share and the prime
minister
was right there with me i want to thank
you prime minister for the united
kingdom's contribution to our common
defense
the uk is one of the handful of nations
5 out of 29. not good but it's going to
get better
really fast in addition to the united
states meeting the 2 percent gdp minimum
defense
spending commitment during the summit i
made clear
all nato allies must honor their
obligations
and i'm pleased to report that we have
received substantial commitments from
members to increase their defense
spending
and to do so in a much more timely
manner in our meetings today
the prime minister and i discussed a
range of shared priorities including
stopping nuclear proliferation
i thanked prime minister may for her
partnership in our pursuit of a
nuclear-free
north korea been a tremendous help the
prime minister and i also discussed iran
we both agree
that iran must never possess a nuclear
weapon
and that i must halt and we must
do it and i'm going to do it and she's
going to do it and we're all going to do
it together
we have to stop terrorism it's the
scourge
we have to stop terrorism and we have to
get certain countries and they've come a
long way i believe
the funding of terrorism has to stop and
it has to stop
now i encourage the prime minister to
sustain pressure on the regime and
she needed absolutely no encouragement
because she in fact also encourages me
and we're doing that and we're doing
that together very closely coordinated
the united kingdom and the united states
are also strengthening cooperation
between our armed forces
who serve together on battlefields all
around the world
today the prime minister and i viewed
several u.s uk
special forces demonstration we saw some
demonstrations today frankly that were
incredible
the talent of these young
brave strong people
we saw it at the royal military academy
at sandhurst seamless
cooperation between our militaries is
really just vital
to addressing the many shared security
threats
we have threats far different than we've
ever had before
they've always been out there but these
are different and they're severe
and we will handle them well we also
recognize the vital importance
of border security and immigration
control
in order to prevent foreign acts of
terrorism within our shores
we must prevent terrorists and their
supporters from gaining admission
in the first place border security is a
national
security problem and in the united
states
we are working very hard to get the
democrats to give us a couple of votes
so we can pass
meaningful and powerful border security
i also want to thank prime minister may
for pursuing fair and reciprocal trade
with the united states once the brexit
process is concluded
and perhaps the uk has left the eu
i don't know what they're going to do
but whatever you do is okay with me
that's your decision
whatever you're going to do is okay with
us just make sure we can trade together
that's all that matters
the united states looks forward to
finalizing a great bilateral trade
agreement with the united kingdom
this is an incredible opportunity for
our two countries and we will seize it
fully
we support the decision of the british
people to realize
full self-government and we will
see how that goes very complicated
negotiation and not an easy negotiation
that's for sure
a strong and independent united kingdom
like a strong and independent united
states is truly a blessing on the world
prime minister may i want to thank you
again for the honor of visiting the
united kingdom a special place
my mother was born here so it means
something
maybe just a little bit extra maybe even
a lot extra
and we had a wonderful visit last night
i think i got to know the prime minister
better than at any time we spent a lot
of time together over
a year and a half but last night we
really
i was very embarrassed for the rest of
the terrible we just
talked about lots of different problems
and solutions to those problems and it
was a great evening
as we stand together this afternoon at
checkers we continue a long tradition of
friendship collaboration
and affection between ourselves and also
between our people
the enduring relationship between our
nations has never
been stronger than it is now so madam
prime minister thank you very much it's
been an honor thank you thank you
thank you mr president thank you thank
you
now we will uh we're going to take four
questions each
i'll uh start off with laura
um thank you very much prime minister
and mr president laura kunsberg bbc news
um mr president you seem rather to have
changed your tune
from what you said earlier this week
when you said that on the current brexit
plan
that would probably kill the possibility
of a trade deal with the uk
our countries are meant to have a
special relationship yet you publicly
criticize the prime minister's policy
and her personally for not listening to
you this week is that really the
behavior of a friend
and prime minister isn't the problem for
you that some
of the things mr trump has said about
your brexit plan
are right it will limit the
possibilities of doing trade deals
easily
in the future can you also tell us how
it felt for him to criticize you in the
way he did in that interview
well maybe i'll go first because i
didn't criticize the prime minister i
have a lot of respect for the prime
minister
and um unfortunately there was a story
that was done
which was you know generally fine but it
didn't put in what i said about the
prime minister
and i said tremendous things and
fortunately we
tend to record uh stories now so we have
it for your enjoyment if you'd like it
but we record when we deal with
reporters it's called
fake news and we solve a lot of problems
with uh the good old recording
instrument but what happens
is that uh look the prime minister as i
really just said
uh she's gonna make a decision as to
what she's going to do the only thing i
ask
of teresa is that we make sure we can
trade that we don't have any
restrictions because we want to trade
with
the uk and the uk wants to trade with us
we're by far their biggest trading
partner and uh
we have you know just a tremendous
opportunity to double triple quadruple
that
so if they're going a slightly different
route and i know they do want
independence it's going to be
independence it's just
your definition uh but uh if they're
going to go a certain route i i just
said that i hope you're going to be able
to
trade with the united states i read
reports where that won't be possible
but i believe after speaking with the
prime minister's people and
representatives and trade experts
it will absolutely be possible so based
on that
uh i uh uh based and based on just trade
in general
and our other relationship which will be
fine but the trade is a little bit
tricky we want to be able to trade and
they want to be able to trade
and i think we'll be able to do that
okay and i think she's doing a terrific
job by the way
thank you mr president and just to
confirm what the president has said
laura
there will be no limit to the
possibility of us doing trade deals
around the rest of the world
once we leave the european union on the
basis of the
agreement that was made here at checkers
and that i've put forward to the
european union
and just to be clear that is an
agreement that delivers on
the brexit vote that we had in 2016 here
in the uk
that delivers what i believe is at the
forefront of people's minds when they
were voting
to leave the european union so at the
end of these negotiations
we will ensure that free movement will
come to an end the jurisdiction of the
european court of justice here in the uk
will come to an end
the sending of vast sums of money every
year to the eu will come to an end
we will come out of the common
agricultural policy we will come out of
the common fisheries policy
and we will ensure by not being in a
customs union that we are able to have
an independent trade policy
and do those trade deals around the
world and as you've heard from the
president
the united states is keen for us we're
keen to work with them
and we will do a trade deal with them
and with others around the rest of the
world
mr president would you like to select
jonathan swann go ahead
uh jonathan jonathan swan from axiorys
mr president two questions if i may um
the first one now
your british trip is coming to a close
could you tell us the three or four
things you hope to achieve
in your meeting with vladimir putin and
the second question
what's the benefit to america of having
tens of thousands of american troops
stationed in europe
thank you so uh i'll be meeting with
president putin on monday
we go into the meeting with a tremendous
meeting that we had
with nato most of you have reported it
correctly
it was certainly it was testy at the
beginning but at the end everybody came
together and they agreed to do what they
should do
and actually what they've committed to
do which you
fully adhered to you didn't have a
problem but some people did
and we left that meeting i think
probably more unified and
wealthier as a group than ever before
so we go in strong we'll be talking to
president putin about a number of things
ukraine we'll be talking about
syria we'll be talking about
other parts of the middle east i will be
talking about nuclear
proliferation because we are
massively you know you know what we've
been doing we've been modernizing and
fixing and buying and
uh it's just a devastating technology
and they likewise are doing a lot
and it's a very very
bad policy we have no choice but
we are massively big and they are
very big and i'll be talking about
nuclear proliferation that would be a
great thing if we could do now it's not
only us it's not only russia and the
united states it's other countries also
but we're the two leaders we would be
the leader
they would be second i guess china would
be third i think we'll all be
talking about that i to me jonathan i
think that would be a tremendous
uh it would be a tremendous achievement
if we could do something on
nuclear proliferation and we'll be
talking about other things i know you'll
ask
will we be talking about meddling and
i will absolutely bring that up i don't
think you'll have any uh
gee i did it i did it you got me there
won't be a perry mason here i don't
think but you never know what happens
right but i will
absolutely firmly ask the question uh
and hopefully we'll have a very good
relationship with russia i
you know i think having and and the
prime minister would agree if
we have a good relationship with russia
and with china and with other countries
that's a good thing not a bad thing so
hopefully that will happen jonathan
okay
yeah uh the troops where though where
well look there is a benefit there's a
uh
psychological benefit and there's a
military benefit there's also a benefit
not to do it i mean i was prepared to do
things that would have been
somewhat harsh yesterday a lot of people
were surprised that nato all came
together at the end
but uh and it wasn't a threat i mean it
was just an unfair situation the united
states was paying
you know anywhere from 70 to 90 and i
choose 90 depending on the way you want
to calculate
uh we were paying 90 for the of the cost
of nato and nato
is really there for europe much more so
than us it helps europe
whether no matter what our military
people or your military people say
helps europe more than it helps us that
being said
it is a great unifier you know we have
29 countries
and there was a lot of love in that room
so i think uh
and we have a lot more than you know
jonathan when you say ten thousand
troops we have a lot more than ten
thousand troops
how much oh ten's up i thought you said
ten thousand
because in germany we have fifty two 000
troops and we have
we have a lot of troops in europe uh
that being said we're helping europe
they're helping us we're all together
and i'm fine with it thank you and
and by the way very importantly they're
now paying their way
in a much more rapid fashion yes thank
you francis
uh francis elliott the times uh prime
minister i wonder whether you agree with
the president of the united states that
immigration has damaged the cultural
fabric
of europe and president perhaps you
could
elaborate on that what do you mean by
that
i think it's been very bad for europe i
think
europe is a place i know very well and i
think that what has
happened is very tough it's a very tough
situation i mean you see the same terror
attacks that i do
we see them a lot we just left some
incredible young men
men and women at sandhurst and they were
showing
us cells and they were showing us things
that frankly 20 years ago nobody even
thought about probably
a lot more recently than that nobody
even thought about i just think it's
changing the culture i think it's a very
negative thing for
europe i think it's very negative i
think having uh
germany and i have a great relationship
with angela
merkel great relationship of germany but
i think that's uh
very much hurt germany i think it's very
much hurt
other parts of europe and i know it's
politically not necessarily correct
to say that but i'll say it and i'll say
it loud
and i think they better watch themselves
because you are changing culture you are
changing a lot of things you're changing
security you're
look at what's happening i mean you take
a look look at what's happening to
different countries that
never had difficulty never had problems
it's a very
sad situation it's very unfortunate but
i do not think it's good for europe and
i don't think it's good for our country
we're
as you know far superior to anything
that's happened before but we have very
bad immigration
laws and we're i mean we're doing
incredibly well considering the fact
that we virtually don't have immigration
laws we have
we have laws that are so bad i don't
even call them laws i call them
it's just like you just walk across the
border you walk across the border you
would put one foot on the land and now
you're tied up in a lawsuit for five
years
it's the craziest thing anyone's ever
seen so uh
i would just make that recommendation to
europe i've made it very loud and clear
i made it yesterday
29 countries total and that's the way i
feel
the uk has a proud history of welcoming
people who are fleeing persecution to
our country we have a proud history of
welcoming people who want to come to our
country to contribute to our economy and
contribute to our society
and over the years overall immigration
has been good for the uk
it's brought people with different
backgrounds different outlooks here to
the uk
and has and we've seen them contributing
to our society and to our economy
of course what is important is that we
have control of our borders what is
important is that we have a set of rules
that enables us to determine who comes
into our country
and of course that is what as a
government we have been doing for a
number of years and will be able to
continue to do
in the future
spent the week taking on nato allies
criticizing prime minister
may on her own soil and i i wonder if
are you giving
russian president vladimir putin the
upper hand heading into your talks given
that you are challenging
these alliances that he seeks to break
up and destroy
see that's such dishonest reporting
because of course it happens to be nbc
which is possibly worse than cnn
possibly possibly let me explain
something
uh we have left nato with more money
with more unity with more spirit
than nato probably has ever had uh we
have
a strong and powerful nato when i became
president we didn't we had people that
weren't paying their bills we had people
that were way down
we were people that weren't following
their commitments in addition to that we
become an
oil exporter which would not have
happened under the past regime or a new
regime if it weren't
us we have built up our military 700
billion dollars and then next year's you
know 716
billion dollars when you look at what
we've done in terms of russia
i guarantee whoever it is in russia
they're saying oh
gee do we wish that trump was not the
victor in that election
we have been far tougher on russia than
anybody
anybody and probably then look i'm not
going to go
down 100 years but certainly we have
been extremely tough on russia
including the fact that when the prime
minister called when they had a horrible
thing happen
right here very close by
she asked would i do something and i
maybe i'd let you
tell the number and it was far greater
than anybody else including the prime
minister
we we expelled how many people
yeah 60. and germany did three as an
example so germany big country powerful
country they did three
the fake news doesn't want to talk about
it so it really is we have been very
strong on russia now with all that being
said
if i had a relationship with putin i
don't know him
i met him twice maybe three times two
and a half times
uh most of you were there when we did we
met them at the
g20 and if we could develop a
relationship
which is good for russia good for us
good for everybody that would be great
have i had a relationship with china you
know we're in a big
trade situation with china as an example
where
uh we're behind every year for many
years 500 billion dollars it's just not
going to happen anymore
so if we got along with countries that's
a good thing if we get along with china
russia that's a good thing not a bad
thing
headlines about the fighting i take your
point about what happened at the end of
nato
the headline he sees isn't the headline
yes there was fighting because i said
you got to put up
you got to put up more money we have to
be stronger we have to be unified
the headline he sees isn't what's
happening during the morning
the headline he sees is what happened in
the afternoon
where we came together as one where
we're
they're putting up billions of dollars
more give you an example
and you know this is a confirmed number
uh
34 billion dollars more
was raised since i became president in
nato
that means that the other 28 countries
have put in 34 billion dollars more into
nato
do you think putin's happy about that i
don't think so but we have a lot of
false reporting in this country
i don't think you have that in your
country do you prime minister
okay go ahead ask ask the prime minister
as well president trump told the sun i
think the deal she is striking
on brexit is not what the people voted
for is he wrong are you offering up
a brexit light and i wonder if we could
get your reaction to him saying that
boris johnson would be a great prime
minister
well first of all on the deal that uh we
have that we have put on the table the
agreement that we've put on the table
as i said earlier in response to laura's
first question
this does deliver on the vote of the
british people the british people voted
to leave the european union
and i heard the turn of phrase that the
president used earlier but let me be
very clear about this we will be leaving
the european union and we are leaving
on the 29th of march 2019.
as we leave the european union we will
be delivering on what people voted for
an end to free movement an end to
sending vast amounts of money to the
european union every year
an end to the jurisdiction of the
european court of justice here
in the united kingdom coming out of the
common fisheries policy coming out of
the common agricultural policy
and ensuring by coming out of the
customs union that we can have an
independent trade policy
that enables us to negotiate trade deals
with the united states and with other
countries
around the rest of the world that's what
the british people voted for
and that's what we will be delivering we
will deliver it
in a way that protects jobs and
livelihoods and meets our commitment to
the border
in between northern ireland and ireland
and uh
robert
boris the president they said uh
unrelated not related to if we have the
tape you could ask sarah get it from
sarah
and we taped the entire interview they
asked about boris johnson i said yeah
how would he be as a prime minister
he'll be a great prime minister he's
been very nice to me he's been saying
very good things about me as president i
think he thinks
i'm doing a great job i am doing a great
job that i can tell you just in case you
haven't noticed
but boris johnson i think would be a
great prime minister
i also said that this
incredible woman right here is doing a
fantastic job a great job
and i mean that and i must say that
i have gotten to know theresa may much
better over the last two days that i've
known her over the last year and a half
i mean we've spent more time in the last
two days
yesterday i had breakfast lunch and
dinner with her then i said what are we
doing tomorrow which is today oh you're
having breakfast and lunch
with theresa may and i'm going to see
you later on again so
but i've actually gotten to know her
better than ever and i think she's a
terrific woman i think she's doing a
terrific job and that brexit is a very
tough situation that's a tough deal
between the borders
and the entries into the countries and
all of the things so
she's going to do the best the only
thing i ask is that
she work it out so that we can have very
even trade because we do not have a fair
deal with the european union right now
on trade
they treat the united states horribly
and that's going to change
and if it doesn't change they're going
to have to pay a very big price and they
know what that price is
so they're coming over on july 25th to
see me
and hopefully we can work something out
but they have barriers that are
beyond belief barriers where they won't
take our farm products they won't take
many of our things including our cars
they charge us
tariffs on cars far greater than we
charge them as you know you know all
these things
and last year so we lost 151 billion
dollars
with the european union so we can't have
that we're not going to have that any
longer okay thank you robert
robert peston itv um mr president
uh how would you characterize your
relationship
with the united kingdom more special
than with other countries
and by the way on farm products i think
on the prime minister's
deal you wouldn't be allowed to export
many of your farm products to the uk
would that be a problem for you
um prime minister the president
said yesterday that he gave you advice
about how to negotiate brexit uh that
you
didn't take that advice i wondered what
that advice was and whether you have any
regrets
about not taking it robert lots of
people give me advice about how to
negotiate with the european union
my job is actually getting out there and
doing it and that's exactly what i've
done and as you know
as we've been going through these
negotiations there have been one or two
skeptical voices perhaps from some of
you
uh arrayed before me today about whether
we would achieve what we would in uh
and achieve in december we had got that
joint report and that joint agreement on
citizens rights and those other issues
we got the implementation period in
march now we've put forward
a proposal that the two proposals the
european commission had put forward are
not acceptable
to the uk we have said no to those and
that's why we have put
our own proposal on the table for the
future which i've said
in answer to other questions delivers on
the on the brexit deal
but also ensures that we can have smooth
trade
with the european union in the future
and in terms of the united states and
trade with the united states
there will be questions on some of the
trade issues about the standards we have
here for certain products
and how we want to deal with those in
the trade deal that will be a matter for
the negotiations
so i would say i give our relationship
in terms of grade the highest level
of special so we start off with special
i would give
our relationship with the uk and now
especially after this
two days with your prime minister
i would say the highest level of special
am i allowed to go am i allowed to go
higher than that i'm not sure but it's
the highest level of special they're
very special people
it's a very special country and as i
said you know i have a relationship
because my mother was born in scotland
so
very important as far as the advice i
did give her a suggestion i wouldn't say
advice
and i think she found it maybe too
brutal and that's so too
because i could see that but i i don't
know if you remember what i said but
i i did give her a certain amount of uh
i gave her a suggestion not advice i
wouldn't want to give her
i'd give her a suggestion uh i could
fully understand why she thought it was
a little bit tough
and maybe at some day she'll do that if
they don't make the right deal she might
very well do what i suggested
that she might want to do but it is not
an easy
thing look look at the united states how
the european union has taken advantage
systematically of the united states on
trade it's a disgrace
so it's not an easy negotiation
john roberts go ahead john no no john
roberts go ahead
cnn's fake news i don't think so i don't
take questions
cnn is fake news i don't take questions
from cnn john roberts of fox
let's go to a real let's go to a real
network
thank you mr president uh some people
have suggested that relations between
the united states and russia are at
their lowest point since the end of the
cold war
and you have stated uh many many times
that you think it's important to have
a better relationship with russia is
there any way
for relations between the united states
and russia to improve
yes as long as putin continues to occupy
crimea
i think so i think i'd have a very good
relationship with president putin
if we spend time together and i may be
wrong you know other people have said
that didn't work out
but i'm different than other people uh i
think that we're being hurt very badly
by the
uh i would call it the witch hunt i
would call it the rigged witch hunt
after watching some of the little clips
i didn't get to watch too much because
i'm here it's a different time zone to
put it mildly but
after watching the people the man that
was testifying yesterday
i call it the rigged witch hunt i think
that really hurts our country and it
really hurts our relationship with
russia
i think that we would have a chance to
have a very good relationship with
russia and a very good chance
a very good relationship with president
putin i would hope so
what is your thinking about improving
relations with russia while they
continue to illegally occupy another
country
well that was uh yes they do and uh if
you're talking about crimea primarily
yeah but
again uh president obama failed
very badly with crimea i don't think he
would have done
that if i were president he took over
crimea and he
actually took it over during the obama
administration i think you will admit
well we'll have to see what happens you
know i'm not bad at doing things if you
look at what i've done
compared to what other people have done
160 days in
there's nobody even close i don't
believe so let's see what happens
but this was an obama disaster
and i think if i were president then he
would not have taken over
crimea during the obama administration
he essentially took over crimea i don't
think he would have done that
with me as president john i have a
question for the prime minister but if i
could follow up you you have taken on
many things you say
you were left uh with by the obama
administration that you
say that you have fixed this is
something that you inherited from the
obama administration the occupation of
crimea
how do you fix it well we're going to
see what happens i mean it's a process
if i
if i knew i wouldn't tell you because
that would put us at a disadvantage but
we'll see what happens we'll see how it
all mells out
but i just want people to understand
that crimea
was a you know it was another bad hand i
got handed north korea we're doing very
well
i you saw the letter yesterday and we're
doing very well look
we haven't had nuclear testing we
haven't had missile launches we haven't
had rocket launches
uh some sites were blown up and we got
back
our hostages our prisoners uh even
before i left
so a lot of good things are happening
there's some good feeling there we'll
see what happens it's a process there's
probably a longer process than anybody
would like but
i'm used to long processes too we
haven't taken off the sanctions the
sanctions are biting
we haven't taken them off but when it
comes to crimea that's something i took
over john there's nothing
much i have to say about it other than
we will look at that just like i'm
looking at many other disasters that
i've taken over i've taken over a lot of
bad hands
and i'm fixing them one by one and i
know how to fix them okay
thank you mr president president trump
says that he made suggestions to you on
what to do about brexit
uh can we ask you if you would make a
suggestion to him on how to handle his
meeting with putin
well i think it's it's very simple we've
been talking about this in fact today
which is what is important
in meeting with president putin and i've
welcomed the meeting with president
putin
but what is important is that the
president goes into this as he is doing
from a position of strength and also
from a position of unity in nato
i think that is very important obviously
we've discussed the activity of russia
in many different ways including
that use of a nerve agent here on the
streets of the united kingdom
and the impact that that has had i
welcomed as i said earlier the very
strong response
the united states gave to that we had
response from around the world but i
think the important thing
is and particularly following the nato
summit the president is going into this
meeting
with president putin from that position
of strength and a position of unity
around that nato table uh
jason
thank you jason goes from the daily mail
um prime minister uh
in the comments yesterday your own mps
uh sort of sided with donald trump
really and and said
uh this this deal that you signed here
at checkers
is going to be bad for trade why can't
you convince your own mps it's a good
idea
and mr president could ask you you've
said brexit it's a
a tough situation what would you do now
would you would you be at the point
where you would walk away
from the talks to show them that you
mean business well first of all on the
uh on the
the issue of trade deals as i've said
earlier what we're
we're negotiating and when we come out
of the negotiations
i want to see and we will have our
ability to have independent trade policy
to set our own tariffs to be that
independent member of the wto
to be able to negotiate trade deals
around the world as we
uh will be doing and we're looking at
obviously at the united states we're
looking at other areas
as well as we've said we're looking at
uh issues like uh
the possibility of some trade deals
around the pacific
pacific area too uh we will negotiate
those trade deals but i also want to
have a good trade arrangement with the
european union
this isn't either or we don't just
replace one with the other
actually the united kingdom is looking
for and can negotiate a situation where
we can have a good trade relationship
with the european union
a great trade relationship a good trade
relationship with the united states and
around the rest of the world as well
and that is what will be good for jobs
good for people's livelihoods
good for prosperity here in the uk
well if you remember i was opening
turnberry the day before
brexit and we had an unbelievably
large number of reporters there because
everybody was there i guess because of
brexit
and they all showed up on the ninth hole
overlooking the ocean and i said
what's going on and they all they wanted
to talk about was brexit and they asked
for my opinion and i think you will
agree that i said i think brexit
will happen and it did happen and then
we cut the ribbon
and the reason i felt it was going to
happen was because of immigration
because i know i think one of the
reasons i got elected was because of
immigration and i felt that
brexit had the upper hand and most
people didn't agree with me if you
remember
barack obama said well that your country
will have to get on the back of the line
if that happened which i thought was a
terrible thing to say frankly
but i said i thought it was going to
happen and it did happen and
i also think uh that
as far as negotiating the deal i
probably would have done
what my suggestion was to the prime
minister but my but she can always do
that
she can do that at some point she can do
what i suggested to her
no well you can't walk away because if
she walks away that means she's
she's stuck can't walk away
but you can do other things but i she
can do
what my suggestion was and my res my
suggestion was you know respectfully
submitted
she will she will do very well i think
she's a very tough negotiator i've been
watching her over the last couple of
days she's a tough
negotiator she's a very very smart and
determined person
i can tell you there are a lot of people
that are looking up now saying gee whiz
you know
she left a lot of people in her wake
she's a
a very smart very tough very capable
person
and uh i would much rather have her as
my friend than my enemy that i can tell
you
go ahead jeff mason from reuters
thank you sir uh mr president
without it good solid header it's i
don't have a good solid head of hair but
thank you sir
going into your meeting
oh boy okay i look you're better without
the hat go ahead
there we go um going into your meeting
with president putin on monday sir
you mentioned both denuclearization and
you mentioned syria can you say exactly
what your message will be to him on
syria what would you like him to say
especially given
assad's gains in the country uh recently
and also
an on denuclearization can you spell out
a little bit
how you expect that to happen in terms
of treaties and in terms of talks
it'll be a slow process don't forget
we're not the only ones that have
nukes and it would be a slow process but
for the world it would be us
and it would be others would have to
come along simultaneously obviously
but i think that uh when i
when the meeting was arranged we both
wanted the meeting
when the meeting was arranged it was
from my standpoint
i don't i didn't go in with high
expectations but you may come out with
something very exceptional but the
uh proliferation is a tremendous
i mean to me it's the biggest problem
in the world nuclear weapons biggest
problem in the world i understand
nuclear look up dr john trump at mit he
was
my uncle many many years a professor i
used to talk nuclear with him and this
is many years ago
uh it's the it's the biggest problem
in my opinion this world has nuclear
weapons so if we could do something to
substantially reduce them i mean
ideally get rid of them it's maybe
that's a dream
but certainly it's a subject that i'll
be bringing up with him
and it's also a very expensive thing
but that's the least important so if we
can if we can do something but
i didn't go in and i was telling the
prime minister before
i didn't go in with high expectations i
mean we have uh we do have
a a political problem where you know in
the united states we have the stupidity
going on pure stupidity
but it makes it very hard to do
something with russia
anything you do it's always going to be
oh russia he loves russia
i love the united states but i love
getting along with russia and china and
other countries
and it will certainly be jeff something
that we bring up and talk about i i
think to me it's
such a big problem syria of course i'm
going to bring that up and i'm going to
bring up ukraine and i'm going to bring
up other subjects also
in terms of syria what exactly you would
like to hear from him and what you would
like russia to do
well that was another one i mean the red
line in the sand was a problem
for us i mean i think you might be in a
different what would you like president
putin to do
now under your watch well i'll tell you
what i'm going to do i'm going to
talk to him about that before i talk to
you and
if something happens it'll be great and
if it doesn't happen uh
i'm not going in with high expectations
but we may come out with some very
surprising things
but relationship is very important and
having relationship with russia and
other countries as i said
a number of times is and i've been
saying actually
for years and i've been certainly saying
it during my campaign
having relationships with other
countries is really a good thing i think
that
i can't really uh overestimate how big
the meeting was yesterday with nato we
went
with something that really was an unfair
situation to something that's
unified i mean they had spirit those
people were
getting up and in the end well we are
committing and we're you know they can't
they can't go you know it's not
like they can go immediately back they
have to go through their parliaments and
their congresses and their
representatives and whoever whatever
form they have but they have to go
through an approval process but i'll
tell you what every single person in
that room was
gung-ho to get it done get the money in
and
even before that as you know 34 billion
and i think that the secretary general
stoltenberg who's doing a terrific job
by the way
he said yesterday that because of
president trump
we've taken in 34 billion dollars more
for nato and i think the number is
actually much higher than that but 34
billion dollars more at least
and again uh that's nothing that my
opponent would have done
my opponent would have it would have
just kept going down you know it was
going down you see what was happening
over the years the numbers were going
down
now the number's way up and now it's
going way up higher and that was
and he will tell you that that was
because of me
prime minister may the president during
his time in
in brussels expressed concern about a
pipeline between russia and germany
do you share those concerns and to
follow up on some of the questioning
from
my colleagues in the british press and
on the american side did you feel
undermined by president
trump's comments in the sun about your
brexit plan
and about boris johnson no look i'm very
clear that our brexit plan will deliver
on what the british people voted for and
we've had an excellent discussion here
as i've said about and as president
trump has said
about the possibility and the intent
that we both have
to have an ambitious trade deal uh going
forward
and i think that's uh that's exactly
where we'll be going and that's uh
very important for both for both of our
countries actually we
stand we have stood shoulder to shoulder
with the united states in so many
different ways over the years as a
result of our special relationship
and we will show that even further
through the trade arrangements that we
will put
in place in the uh in the future and i
have to just just to finish off jeff
just to finish off uh i have to say
i said to that paper the sun uh and they
seem like two very nice people
but i said that theresa may is a
one of them's nice but i said i'm
sitting here
oh good where is that person where did i
say nice things about theresa may please
oh good okay if you reported them that's
good okay where on the internet
i said very good things i thank thank
you very much for saying that no i said
very good things about her
i didn't think they put it in but that's
all right they didn't put it in the
headline i wish they put that in the
headline that's one of those things
and she's a total professional because
when i saw her this morning i said i
want to apologize because i said such
good things about you she
said don't worry it's only the press i
thought that was very
i thought that was very professional i
might add joe i might add
uh well let's see that's called being
don't worry
i've been they've been doing it to me
and i do it to them uh i
i do say though the pipeline you asked
about the pipeline to me
it is a tragedy i think it's a
horrific thing that's being done where
you are feeding
billions and billions of dollars from
germany primarily and other countries
but primarily from germany into the
coffers of russia
when we're trying to do something so
that we have peace in the world
i think it's a horrible thing that
germany's doing i think it's a horrible
mistake and
as much as i like angela i was very open
in saying it i think it's a
horrible thing that you have a pipeline
coming from russia
and i believe that germany's going to be
getting 50 60 or even i've heard numbers
of 70
of their energy coming in from russia
and how can you be working for
peace and working from strength when
somebody has that kind of power over
your country i don't think it's good
you're not working from strength you've
given up all of your strength
i think it's very bad for germany very
bad for the german people
and i don't think it's very good for
nato you want another truth so
okay
we've uh just just we said we would take
four questions each and we've taken four
questions each
um just on the the uh pipeline issue on
the north stream we've been talking to
the germans about this
we've been talking to other uh countries
within the european union about this
and while we continue to sit around the
eu table this will be something that
will be discussed
at the european union table and
obviously we'll make our views known
there mr president thank you can you
share your views with us
your position look the the we have been
discussing this
with germany the president has made
clear his concerns about what is
happening angela merkel made her
uh position clear within the european
union there are discussions to be held
on this
issue of of uh nordstrom 2 uh and we're
talking to other countries within the
european union
and i think the president said earlier
in response to a question about a future
meet a meeting he was going to have
that he'd tell you uh what was uh
happening after that meeting
and uh we you will see what comes out
from the european union and while we're
a member of the eu because we still are
until the 29th of march 2019
and then we're leaving thank you very
much thank you
this conference ends with applause uh
president trump being friendly and
perhaps a little contrite
at this checkers news conference he
talked about the
enduring relationship that has never
been
stronger he also uh described the sun
story that's caused so much
upset today across five pages of our
biggest selling newspaper
as fake news that was the phrase that he
used although i'm sure that there is a
a recording of it that we've been
broadcasting but we'll check it out for
you in a bit more detail
you also apologize